un campus flambant neuf au coeur de
toronto l'université de l'ontario
français a été inauguré en grande pompe
avec la présence de plusieurs
personnalités politiques il y a
finalement une institution au coeur de
la radio pat épaules les francophones
cette institution est une revendication
de longue date dans la provence et le
chemin vers sa création a été tumultueux
aujourd'hui une fête naissance
mais bon au sein que la période de
gestation et l angle près de trois ans
après le jeudi noir des franco-ontariens
lorsque le gouvernement ford avait mis
sur la sellette le projet de création de
l'unef conduisant à de vastes
manifestations dans la provence c'est un
nouveau départ est l'aboutissement d'un
partenariat entre l'ontario et ottawa
l'uef de même que nos collèges et nos
institutions universitaires ont un rôle
primordial à jouer afin de non seulement
remédier aux lacunes existantes du
marché du travail le décor est moderne
les espaces communs spacieux et peuvent
accueillir 2000 étudiants pour le moment
150 étudiants ont fait leur rentrée cet
automne majoritairement en virtuel car
75 % des étudiants viennent de
l'étranger dieudonné lui vient de
montréal il a été séduit par les
programmes comme culture numérique
économie et innovation sociale qu'il
juge novateurs aux grandes que ceux
conçus
originaux mais achats et torontoises
elle a hâte de connaître la pleine
effervescence d'un campus j'ai parlé
avec
et on s'entend très bien mais
malheureusement
les derniers mois n'ont pas été de tout
repos pour la jeune institution qui a eu
de la difficulté à recruter des
étudiants canadiens il faut être patient
il faut il faut savoir que le cycle de
recrutement va souvent prendre trois ans
quatre ans en attendant on mise sur
l'immigration et on prépare le terrain
auprès de la jeunesse francophone qui
brandit déjà haut et fort ses couleurs
ici camif high rise and radio canada
toronto